welcome back to New rockstars this is
the road to Daredevil Born Again a
re-watch series we are embarking upon to
break down all 39 episodes of the three
seasons of Daredevil on Netflix because
with Born Again coming we need to look
back at what is arguably the best Marvel
title currently streaming on Disney plus
and this video is brought to you by
Squarespace more on them later we are
Eric Voss and Jessica Clements yeah I
like to call ourselves Jerica and Jerica
is back and we are breaking down season
one episode one into the Ring of
Netflix's Daredevil born again is set to
be released on Disney Plus in Spring of
2024 and we can't wait to see what
Charlie Cox is going to be doing back in
Hell's Kitchen because last time we saw
him he's in California he's in
California now so yeah get your ass back
to Hell's Kitchen yeah lose that tan
what's going on go back to being pale
like buzz said we're doing a re-watch of
the Daredevil series to bring you a
breakdown of the Easter eggs and details
you might have missed the first time
watching it because this came out ages
ago these things may or may not come
back in the Disney plus series I know
that a lot of them won't but there's
little Parts little pieces that could
make their their way back into the
original series or into the Disney plus
Born Again series let's just jump into
it okay so first the Marvel logo flips
like Pages through a comic book and we
hear the pages shuffling now currently
and most often the two different logos
are for more of the like MCU versus
Marvel characters that are not in the
MCU like the Sony and Netflix properties
but this OG page shuffling intro is
still on the Disney plus roster all the
way up until the first Doctor Strange
movie they use this intro up until the
very first Doctor Strange which is phase
three they use this a lot and I think
it's a big reason why a lot of people in
a lot of people's minds that all these
titles were still part of the same
broader Marvel universe so after that we
open on battle in Jack Murdoch play by
David Keith walking through a chaotic
traffic accident scene to find his
nine-year-old son a young Matt Murdoch
played by Skylar Gartner lying on the
ground with his face covered in some
toxic goo we know now that that toxic
goo is what blinded him all those years
ago and an elderly man says this yo boy
it pushed me out of the way he saved my
life this sets up Matt as a rare
superhero who didn't wait until after he
got his powers to perform acts of
heroism no good deed goes unpunished
though as the goo does make Matt lose
his eyesight and it's horrible and in
this really sad transition we see the
edges of the screen began to meld and
corrode like film burning in a projector
it's sort of scary but the same chemical
reaction it takes to burn the film kind
of mirrors the same reaction the acid is
giving to poor young Matt's eyes yeah
totally but you know what if you think
about it the last thing Matt does see is
a bright sky over this city it does
leave him with a kind of idealism that I
think will fuel him as an adult attorney
I kind of hope that this city is not
Beyond Redemption and that he has to
stay in this ring and fight till the
final round and then from this we
transition to the present day a truly
awesome scene that's just met talking to
confessional for over three minutes
straight mostly interrupted and folks
this is actoon Charlie Cox plays the
scene with tears in his eyes and pride
in his voice and you just know that he's
gonna bring it for the rest of the
series from this moment on he tells
father lansom about his dad's boxing
career how he was known for being able
to take a punch and as we see throughout
the series this is something Matt
clearly inherited from his papa because
this dude has taken brutal beatdowns on
the regs and just like his dad he always
gets back up this scene also serves us
foreshadowing formats and vegetable
superhero Persona since he says his
grandmother used to say hey be careful
of the Murdoch boys they got the devil
in but I do think it's interesting to
point out that Matt says about his dad
yeah guys he went up against Houston
which I think Fortel's own fighting
style taught to him by another piece of
wood stick like stick from the oak tree
you could say yeah and it goes on to say
his eyes would go dead
hands of the slides like he wasn't
afraid of anything yeah yeah just think
about that a fighter with inactive eyes
but a Man Without Fear slowly marching
up to his enemies with his hands at his
sides unafraid this is how Matt struts
into that hallway kill box in episode
two yes I can't wait to even get into
episode two but now it turns out Matt
isn't here to confess his sins not at
all he's here to ask for forgiveness for
something he's about to do the most
Godfather act that he that could happen
and this isn't a pilot episode you guys
so then we jump to the docks that night
to intercept some human trafficking if
you remember this horrible scene where
Turk played by Rob Morgan says I'm
getting a thousand dollars ahead for
y'all oh and then proceeds to offer them
a bucket before forcing them into a
shipping container Turk is also a
character from the comics if you didn't
know and he is still a petty criminal a
petty thief and the opening shot of this
scene is gorgeous the city skyline frame
between the two shipping containers
really Hammer home the fact that the
crime and Corruption have taken over
this city and we get our first fight
scene of the series and it is
it's so good it's so good and it's so
funny so the choreography is impeccable
and it's so fast and so tight and yes
brutal but I just love this guy seated
this Russian guy who's eating a sandwich
it doesn't move during the entire fight
but who ultimately gets knocked out
anyway maybe he should have just offered
mad some of his sandwich I don't even
know what I it was so cartoony but it's
still so good additionally Matt's Man in
Black look is inspired by the Frank
Miller Man Without Fear Comics run we go
from Matt brutally beating the crap out
of these guys something he had mentioned
his dad would do in the ring when he
said something in him would snap to the
opening credits remember the last time
we heard Daredevil's intro music was in
She-Hulk at the Daredevil introduction
we see the elements of his City forming
in this blood-like paint genuinely this
is my favorite marble intro overall uh
overall I would arguably uh for a series
because the Black Panther reconna
forever intro is really good but like
this this is the music the look
so there's water towers churches
skyscrapers come into view along with
the Lady Justice portrayed here as she
often is blindfolded and holding scales
we also see an angel statue half cover
in her face which is definitely giving
me weeping angels from Doctor Who if you
guys have seen it the creatures who
could only move when they weren't being
watched essentially coming to life only
when people were blind to their true
nature how is this not about Daredevil
the whole thing is set to this beautiful
haunting original score composed by John
Paseo and Braden Kimball yeah
it stays with us and I totally agree
with you Jess this is just beautiful
imagery that puts us in the right mood
every time we watch it's one of the few
Netflix shows that I would not skip
through the credits of never I never did
I want to get in that Vibe every time
and this liquid that's bleeding over the
city is actually meant to be the liquid
that blinded Matt as a kid this was
according to Patrick Claire the head of
the design team behind this they
considered that toxic corruption seep
into the city with its reconstruction
efforts after the Avengers battle of New
York to be linked to the same liquid
that poison Matt is a kid and all of it
all of it here is just so visceral so
wet don't you feel like you need a bath
after you watch this I do but I love it
it's like Peta throw in a bucket of
blood on me
to wear fur coats every every time I get
but I just like this
like this every time we watch this
episode nothing nothing in Hell's
Kitchen is left unstained by the blood
alright so as we start the episode we
meet foggy Nelson Matt's best friend and
business partner played by Elton Henson
who you might recognize from the Mighty
Ducks movies what was it 10 Things I
Hate About You was that one of them no
it was in uh she's all that uh he's also
Idle Hands a very a very Niche movie for
horror fans Idle Hands he's a great kid
foggy calls Matt who's still in bed he's
beaten Bruce or the night before this
really just sets up the ongoing theme of
Matt's work life clashing with his
double life as a dude who spends his
nights beating down criminals and this
is something we've seen other
superheroes struggle with before which
just really shows the whole work-life
balance thing but in a new much higher
Stakes life and Matt and foggy meet with
the realtor and we get the first mention
of the Battle of New York in this series
this office was barely touched by the
incident which is why it's on the market
already so this is a big deal this is we
have to talk about this for a second
because when this Daredevil series was
first produced for Netflix it was under
a different division of Marvel
entertainment than what Kevin feige
oversaw at Marvel Studios all of the MCU
references in these episodes would go in
One Direction like Daredevil would
reference the Battle of New York or Hulk
or Iron Man or something but Avengers
movies would never reference darable
explicitly now all this would change
after Netflix canceled Daredevil in 2018
after season three and then a couple
years after that the rights reverted to
Disney Marvel Studios and that's when
they brought in Charlie Cox and cameos
Matt Murdoch and Spider-Man no way home
and She-Hulk and now the new series the
Daredevil born again now coxa said that
born again will not be a season four but
since these shows did all the work to
cohere to the logic of the MCU I think
it's still possible that born again
could imply these events exist in some
rarely discussed backstory for Murdoch
and Wilson Fisk and Frank Castle and
born again then again they did recast
the character Vanessa and they appear to
be shooting flashbacks to earlier eras
with different child actors so born
again could take the DraStic move and
say these Netflix seasons were in a
separate Universe in the MCU was but
with Cox it did not real playing the
characters we are hoping that the MCU
backstory at least somewhat mirrors what
we saw in these Netflix episodes because
they are so so good and they totally
inform the way these actors are
approaching the characters now
absolutely that's the part where I'm
like I think it's still gonna be a part
it still has the heart of what the
Netflix Daredevil was and it's gonna
have the same like motives that the
comics even have so I don't think it's
completely different but it is a
different story look we're gonna get
back to the video in one second but I
gotta tell you about Squarespace not
only are they making it possible for me
to do this video but they could be
making it possible for you to do
honestly whatever you want to do online
that's because Squarespace makes it easy
to make an awesome website that lets you
engage with your audience and sell
anything you need your products content
you create even your time Squarespace is
the all-in-one platform for building
your brand and growing your business
online if you're making videos
Squarespace can help Squarespace can
help you create Pro level videos
effortlessly the Squarespace video
studio app will help you make and share
engaging videos to tell your story grow
your audience and drive sales but hey
maybe making videos isn't your thing
because you're more of a social media
buff well no problem you can display
posts from any profile you want on your
website and automatically push website
content to your favorite social media
channels so your followers can share it
too no matter what you're doing
squarespace's analytic tools will help
you learn where your traffic and sales
are coming from and so you can improve
your website and build a marketing
strategy based on either your top
keywords or most popular products and
content so head to squarespace.com for a
free trial and when you're ready to
launch go to squarespace.com new
rockstars to save 10 off your first
purchase of a website or domain let's
get back into this so Madden foggy argue
over what kinds of clients they should
be taking on and just as Matt says
battle for one innocent client we cut to
Karen Page covered in blood holding a
knife next to a dead body we find out
later that that dead body with Daniel
Fisher who worked in the legal
department of Union Ally Kieran is
played by Deborah Ann wool who I think
must have it in all of her contracts
that she can only be introduced in TV
shows covered in blood and crying and
screaming
hey she just walked through the opening
credit sequence of this show you know
she just got covered in that blood and
just screamed yeah great idea great idea
foggy gets tipped off by his cop buddy
Brett Mahoney that Karen is there at the
station and man foggy swoop in to save
the day Matt uses super hearing to
determine that Karen is innocent and
boom they've got their first ever client
we cut to off-duty police officer Clyde
Farnam which is also the name of an
early Daredevil comic book villain The
Marauder he's eating his lunch at a city
park chessboard when Wesley Wilson fists
right hand man sits down next to him
Farnam owes money to the mobster
Rigoletto 28 957 dollars would be exact
Wesley explains that now that regoletto
is retired Fisk has acquired his books
and he's calling in his debt he doesn't
want the money he's owed however he
wants to use Farnam to get to Karen West
threatens farnham's daughter Tracy by
showing a live feed video of her being
watched by a Hitman if you make deals
with Loan Sharks don't have children
that's like loan sharking 101 because
they're just gonna come over there and
hunt him and kill them Wesley then
comments on her Monet shirt which is so
creepy but listen hear me out for a
second he says what is it about college
girls and Monet t-shirt yeah so our
analysis plays a big part in this show
since Fisk meets his eventual girlfriend
Vanessa and our dealer at her Gallery
when he's buying some art also fun fact
at one point in his life moday developed
terrible cataracts which rendered him
legally blind and unable to see most
colors other than red which is the main
color he painted in during this period
he eventually had surgery to remove the
cataracts and went back to pain in his
signature blues and purples yeah that's
a really good point Jess because in
episode 5 Matt will explain to Claire
Temple how he perceives the world as an
impressionistic painting what he calls a
world on fire and so we could totally
see him as a Monet unable to close his
eyes to the fire and trying his best to
remember those water lilies Knight
rabbits the right Monet right not Monet
yes yes monated lilies right now yeah
Monet was trash Monet was the best
on it so we're back at the office Matt
and foggy discuss Karen's case foggy
wants to take a plea deal but Matt says
he believes her which causes foggy to
tell Matt that he hasn't always shown
the best judgment where stunning women
with questionable character are involved
and if that ain't in a lecture reference
I will eat my hat but for Matt he
literally is Lady Justice he's got the
blindfolds on he can sense through this
Supernatural ability whether or not
people are telling the truth just by
listening to the heartbeat and it kind
of makes us always fall in love with him
he said this was She-Hulk and She-Hulk
it's like his coolest superpower but
back at the jail Karen is attacked by
Farnham who happens to shoot around her
neck to try to make it seem like she
hung herself but this lady has claws and
she uses them to claw out what a
fartum's eyes and scream for help Matt
and foggy legally threatened detectives
Blake and Hoffman for almost letting
their client get the Epstein treatment
but Blake doesn't take it too well
you take that toll with me again I don't
care if you're blind I'll kick the [__]
out of you and so Charlie Cox ever so
slightly smirks after he hears that and
I just love it because you know he's
probably thinking how hard he would beat
Blake if he ever tried to get into it
with him so Karen lays out the reason
why everyone's trying to frame her or
kill her it's because she has evidence a
union Ally her from her place of
employment was using its government
construction contracts to embezzle money
and you gotta wonder if any of these
Shady construction folks know Adrian
tombs another guy involved with a
salvage and reconstruction of New York
yes Matt tells Karen that she can stay
at his place because I guess foggy lives
with his mom or has a bachelor pad or
something I don't know why he like
immediately instigated but whatever go
off go off Daredevil you fine as hell
Daredevil's DPS also love lighting a
night scene there is one thing to take
away from this a big thing from the
pilot episode those DPS love lighting a
night scene the windows illuminate like
daylight hitting stained glass making
Matt look like he's back in the church
like every moment of his life he's been
spending in that church confessional
Booth the light in the stairwell is
literally bright green Matt's apartment
is illuminated by the giant light up
sign that casts a heavy Shadow on his
red Furniture it perfectly contrasts
with the green hallway and it's just so
fun and it's dark and it's gritty we see
later on he does almost everything in
the dark and it feels like it's to give
the audience the same depth assuming
that he doesn't need it but we do so
when we see the fight scenes later on
keep in mind the people he's fighting
can barely see they're playing ball in
his court and they are losing baby it's
insane I love it so good a pilot episode
you guys please go back and watch it
after you watch our breakdown I didn't
expect the sexual attention between Matt
and Karen to immediately hit like this
uh we know they had relationships in the
comics and what happens further down the
line but this all felt like him and
She-Hulk all over again baby like he is
a fuckboy but and he is in the comics he
is in the Daredevil Netflix and he
absolutely is gonna be in Disney's MCU
it's I I love him I love him so one seed
and Matt tells Karen about his
unfortunate accident that ultimately
left him blind leaving out the toxic goo
details this is where we learn later
that Karen has something that Fisk needs
that flash drive of evidence we learned
that they're trying to discredit her by
Framing her for murder then after the
second incident they plan to make it
look like a suicide and hey it's all
swept under the rug as Matt says this is
when the Daredevil chess game begins
Matt can hear Karen's heartbeat and
she's lying about keeping the
incriminating files you don't lie to
your lawyer that's like lying to your
therapist you don't do it
we jump to Union Allied construction or
at least one of their construction sites
it's it's literally an unfinished
Skyscraper the most villainy grounded
villain Lair I've ever seen in the MCU
history here we have the drug lord
Madame gal the brother traffickers
Anatolia and Vladimir Leland owsley
Wesley and Nobu yep and when Madam cow
initially speaks we do not get subtitles
which I really love because it makes me
feel like we're just one of the villains
there but with her horrifying past I
wouldn't question anything she says also
good to know that Madame GAO is a
primary antagonist scoring up with Dany
and Iron Fist she spans two MCU series
as a super villain and she's awesome now
Lila nowsley is featured in Marvel
Comics as a shady businessman like he is
in the Dirt Devil series but he also had
the power of limited flight due to a
special serum that allowed him to Glide
for distances thus the word owl in his
name he also had slightly enhanced
senses and Talons as a bird Enthusiast
this would be my preferred superpower
but uh
I would never want to be a bird that can
slightly Glide that would be the worst
superpower I wouldn't be a flightless
bird just an emu I just want to molt and
just make people uh really uncomfortable
by staring at them for too long then
there's Anatoly and Vladimir the other
gangsters who we follow in this season
and Nobu who doesn't really have stories
in the comics but later in episode 4 we
see a tattoo representing the ten rings
of course you know of the legend of the
chongqi movie that we all know and love
on Vladimir's shoulder so these boys
have been committing crimes for a long
time with a lot of shady Partners we
figure out through Wesley that this
employer AKA Wilson Fisk not only is
business and insurance money and best
Lane but in human trafficking as well
I'd assume all these crime and drug
lords median and Hell's Kitchen must go
through Fisk so our man oversees it all
now we get another mention of the first
Avengers movie when owlsley says Heroes
and their consequences are why
we have our current opportunities which
applies not only to the 2012 Avengers
but also in regards to the sokovia
Accords villains like Baron Zemo
flourish with the Segovia Accords
because it helped create a divide in The
Avengers allowing Zemo to slide in and
control them even more villains are
nothing without Heroes every villain in
the MCU in some way is formed by the
hero literally and figuratively while
owsley celebrates the new vigilante
scene that they can exploit the damages
he may leave behind in Hell's Kitchen
Wesley questions it knowing that Fisk
won't like these inconveniences to
continue and it's only in Vladimir too
much pride to even be working through
Wesley big question whether or not Fisk
is doing a good job seen as the Rival
parashka is still in business and this
promise to take him out to which Leslie
responds we're handling it yeah another
death is upon us my friends
anytime a villain says we're handling it
yeah four people will die okay so Matt
with his super hearing here's Karen
sneak out in the night she snuck back to
her apartment to retrieve the evidence
the flash drive was locked in an air
vent in the bathroom Kudos carrying good
place in hiding and the world's most
horrible timing though hiding in the
shadows is one of Wesley's goons the
same man at the park watching farnam's
daughter rant he immediately knocks
Karen to the ground but fear not
Daredevil is there we get a fun fight
scene in Karen's dark apartment until
they're thrown out the window hitting
the fire escape pulse then hitting the
cold wet pavement we slowly transitioned
to Young Matt in his childhood home
asleep on the small kitchen table in the
same position he was on the ground some
things just never change in the in the
Daredevil Universe his dad has just come
back from a fight his face is completely
pummeled he wakes young Matt who fell
asleep studying and right when his
father says I never studied look where
it got me you see the two-part
realization a his dad wants Matt to
succeed so he doesn't have to follow in
his footsteps B when he says look you
see the sadness in his face because his
son can't see him so he raises Matt's
little hand to his feel his face
crumbled and bleeding literally onto the
kitchen table so he knows what not to do
this scene can also just be confusing
because you're wondering what really
drives Matt Murdoch and this is the
pilot episode still you guys so we
shouldn't really know but we're starting
to see it at times it's his father his
values his beliefs I think it's all the
above especially in the scene where his
dad saw fighting as a curse and Matt
slowly finds it as an advantage these
flashbacks will come out when big
defining moments for Matt come through
the flashback ends with his dad saying
come on Maddie get to work get to work I
love it and just like that Matt Ryan is
from the pavement and starts beating the
crap out of rants now we've seen
terrible fights so much from this pilot
but the choreography is still so so good
in slow motion it's highlighting the
fact that this man can dodge swings from
a knife his hearing is impeccable at one
point he hears the metal chains and he
chokes rants with it
yeah and Karen rightfully paranoid begs
Daredevil not to take the flash drive to
the police so he takes it to the New
York bulletin not to be confused of The
Daily Bugle because we know what they
would do with it
well with the Daily Bugle do with it
just ruin it Parker put it on my
butthole yeah
but the New York bulletin is kind of
like the newspaper that's featured in a
lot of these shows we saw it in Agent
Carter we saw in Jessica Jones and Cloak
and Dagger another Netflix Marvel
related series and the flash drive is
pinned to a barely conscious rants New
York bulletin immediately publishes the
union Allied Scandal didn't really fact
check it no time we gotta get this they
didn't they didn't it immediately
dropped they did not care they were like
oh there's a crumbled man with a pinned
flash drive to him it must be true I
will I will give them that they did not
double check their sources but go on
continue so Wesley ties up the Loose
Ends and the next step on fisk's road of
Destruction is figuring out who Nelson
and Murdoch are because they are Karen's
lawyers who are these guys later we see
the real time effect of Wesley tying up
those loose ends we see Leland
transferring money and changing the
accounts for Union Ally then we see
Farnham with a gunshot to the head dead
in the kitchen his poor daughter finding
him this way I guess this is Masters a
bust next we see rants hung in his cell
by his own sheet getting that Epstein
treatment
get in that Epstein treatment again the
Epstein 101 a ton of people are stacking
large amounts of package heroin whoa
these people are all way into packaging
like an assembly line and they are all
blind Madame GAO is an efficient one all
their eyes look like they've been
purposely blinded with acid and the
scarring is a key detail it definitely
mirrors Matt's unintentional accident we
know Matt's gonna come in contact with
this organization soon just because of
this scene alone and they've also been
stamping each package with what is that
the steel serpent logo that is the
heroine produced by the hand of course
the villains of Iron Fist who show up in
season 2 of Daredevil and the Defenders
I can't wait to get my hands on that
heroine well we're back at the empty Law
Firm Karen's made her Grandma's recipe
for the two boys and again this sexual
tension you can cut it with a butter
knife we begin to close the pilot
episode with the newfound friendship and
colleagues Nelson Murdock and Paige
perfect closing to an amazing pilot Matt
enters fogwell's gym he takes his
glasses off and starts beating the hell
out of a punching bag as the camera
zooms out we see the poster for Creole
vs Murdoch which is Matt's father and
that's the fight that he had all those
years ago the symbolism here what got
his father killed is knocking on the
devil's door literally and he doesn't
care it's in his DNA but it's also his
way of life and it's so sad we see Nobu
going over Hell's Kitchen New York City
it's like an entire grid plan separated
by different Avenues and Street numbers
the one highlighted seems to say black
sky and I found this out after a lot of
Google translating and we later find out
this refers to the young boy from Japan
found by the hand in episode 7. we learn
later in the season that this young boy
is not your average child Matt even
noted his pulse sounded different but he
couldn't Define how it's clearly set up
that the child is a weapon and it's
something very important to note for
later in the season that we'll get into
they established so much in this pilot
it's a really well written
well-structured well-directed pilot that
like gives us a ton of information and
hooks us into the world with all this
mythology I love it and we see a broken
nose Turk still healing for Matt's beat
down the beginning of the episode buying
illegal weapons from the back of a truck
never a good sign a white van speeds
into a shot and Anatolian Vladimir get
out pull a man from his car and beat him
senseless Vladimir kidnaps the boy and
drives away as a dad plays beaten on the
ground and we cut to Daredevil
overlooking the city with a super
hearing again my favorite of his
superpowers and he listens to the
citizens and hears The Echoes of this
young child the same boy getting
kidnapped and thus the episode closes as
it began with a son crying out for a
father but this episode is titled into
the ring and here in Hell's Kitchen the
ropes bind all of us onto that mat Matt
Matt's father didn't want his son to end
up in the ring like he did but now Matt
assuming the role is paternal Guardian
is not about to let another kid get
stained by the blood of this wet town oh
God this pilot is so good you guys it's
so good it's one of my favorite Pilots
because how the hell did you get all of
that information in one hour one hour
get all that information we get his
backstory we get his father we get
everything that has to do with religion
we get three additional main characters
introduced four four or five villains
with each all different motives working
different versions of being a villain
this is an insane pilot you guys this is
wild I'm telling you currently it is I
mean I'm someone who loves Loki I love
One Division but I think Daredevil is
the best Marvel title currently
streaming on Disney plus so I can't wait
to go through all of these episodes and
break them all down with you Jess this
is so much fun to be able to chat with
you I love doing this
I'll watch it Daredevil over and over
and over again I don't care it is the it
was my favorite thing in the world okay
all right we're doing this we're on the
road to born again and we're not getting
up we're not we're skipping past all the
off ramps so a reminder to subscribe to
our new channel the Deep dive I'm
working on some fun stuff over there but
he can support this growing Network by
grabbing something from our merch store
nerd riot.shop subscribe to new
rockstars on YouTube and all the social
platforms follow Jessica Lulu underscore
Clements you can follow me at eavos and
we'll see you next time as we keep going
down this road Daredevil
thank you
[Music]